[Music]
okay first thing super quick so have you
guys heard of this twitter account it's
called new york times first set have you
heard of it no okay so
it's kind of just like this fun little
twitter account where
they track all of the articles being
published by the new york times and then
they find words that are published for
the first time and it's just kind of
like a fun thing because i'll send you
guys this
or i'll post it in the doc
this is a link to
a couple of the ones uh that they
publish so like dead ass for example was
a word like first found in the new york
times march 2019
doom scrolling may 2020 uh tech bro
apparently was january 2022 like that
surprises me so this is just kind of
like a fun thing but i was thinking that
this
should exist for jobs so on indeed or
glassdoor or something
there's a really really quick
transition period these days between
like just completely new jobs coming to
market
and i think there should be an account
that tracks these like oh this is the
first time i've seen like i don't know
where i saw this but there's like
professional falconer like what who does
that how much do they get paid i don't
know but i'm surprised to know it exists
and i'm sure there's many more practical
jobs out there that are coming to market
that people should know about and so
someone should just create the
equivalent of this instead of the new
york times it should be for indeed how
do they do this that's great
how do they track every word and check
if it's ever been said before
i think it's just a scraper i mean i
don't know exactly how they set it up
but i don't think it would actually be
that by the way this has 200 000
followers so for that person out there
who's just been grinding trying to put
out great content that has like 3 000
followers just know you could have been
tweeting out like single word
things from the new york times and got
200 000 followers
i actually think that's a great idea
have you guys seen the uh remember how
we talked about this kid that was
tracking elon musk's private jet on
twitter now he's tracking all the
private jets and private yachts of all
the russian oligarchs great pivot and
shout out shout out
also elon offered him five thousand
dollars and he turned it down he's like
no i'm going to keep doing my thing but
both of his accounts have a lot of five
grand for elon
stop tracking him yeah yeah because elon
was like i don't want people to know
where i am what a stupid thing if you're
gonna if you're gonna come and offer
someone money
do it right five thousand dollars
that's how you should reply
grand um i think this is cool stuff i
actually think this is a wonderful idea
um
i also think that companies would pay
for this right as in like
companies that have competitors want to
know what their competitors are doing
and so like we're launching something at
hubspot soon and i've already gotten an
email from someone who works at
techcrunch who's like hey saw this on
your site or like they basically dug
something up that we publish
and they're like what's going on here
and imagine you have the same thing
where you're like oh i saw like sales
forces you know hiring for these roles
or i didn't know that was a role at
netflix i think companies would pay for
that intel that's actually crazy
fascinating if you could aggregate like
let's say that you're in the me
when i was at the hustle i cared about
what like there's like 30 companies that
i cared about what they were doing it
would be kind of interesting to act if i
would have paid a monthly fee and i
would have gotten a daily email with
like the movement and people's job
job listings yeah that's that's what i
was gonna say i don't think it's so
interesting like the the falconer or
whatever it's like oh whatever someone
made up a random job but
oh like we see this a lot where it's
like oh netflix is hiring a web 3
engineer that means they're probably
trying to explore something in that
space and so you can kind of get a sense
of what direction somebody's going oh
they're hiring enterprise sales okay
they're trying to go up market right so
there's a competitive intelligence that
comes from these but i think that i do
think that exists i've seen
people tracking these i don't know if
they're just doing it for their own fun
or if there's like a service that tracks
that uh but it is kind of interesting i
like that all right what else you got
steph
oh by the way i should say one more
thing
i love more thing about this hilarious
story i went into work one day and my
buddy neil who's like a programmer at
our company he was standing at the
coffee machine making a coffee it was
like 10 a.m
and i hadn't even said anything to him
yet we were just standing next to each
other and he just goes
these are my first words
he's like he did he realized he hadn't
spoke that day yet he like got to work
to the coffee machine and like he had
started programming like his commute he
didn't talk to anybody he was at his
destination he just started these are my
first words
and i thought that [__] was so funny and
uh it actually is great when he said
that i realized how funny neil is and so
we've replaced our marketing person with
neil he's uh our iphone programmer and
he wrote all of the release notes for
our apps because he was just hilarious
and he was like loki hilarious but these
are my first words i'll never forget
that
how does that relate relate to that
because it's like a word tracker you
know the first time the new york times
said this word so that's how i thought
of that
first time neil
it's interesting thing about what are
your first words every day
right like
what's coming at your mouth for the
first time every day
mine's usually like like a grump it's
like a [__] when i say enough you know
what i mean
exercise or something and i'm like oh
[__] it's usually my first word
well that explains a lot
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing uh i can't believe we didn't talk
about this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
all right what else doing
uh i guess related to companies hiring
so you guys are no mischief right it's
this like company that does these crazy
stunts they're on i think stunt number
70 and i
their latest stunt i thought was really
interesting and relates to this idea of
just like creative hiring so if you
scroll down
tell me about what mischief is i don't
entirely get it because they raised
funding but when you explain what they
are i'm like who what grown adult would
trust this child with money it's like
south park or saturday night live it's a
weekly
show it's like a weekly sketch
uh but it's just done through code they
make a website instead of like a video
making a joke they make a website that's
a joke yeah
but is it exactly does it make money
i think it does i don't know how much
they've made they've raised three and a
half million dollars so i don't know
like you're saying i don't know who
those investors are what they're looking
from mischief but
just to give like two examples so one of
them recently was i think it's like
called
tuntin i don't know why it's called that
but basically it's called
the game of death online which you sign
up you get an account and you pay 10 to
join the game and all you have to do is
log in daily to stay alive and the last
person who stays alive gets all the
money so it's just kind of like these
silly quirky games but
the last one they did was
they also do like commentary through
their game so it was a commentary on in
this case the msat so they got people to
pay fifty dollars
to take the msot and the highest score
one it's basically like a
their version of the sats um and the
person who got the highest score won the
entire pot so they didn't actually have
that many people did it they had 500
people
who did it but it reminded me of
something you guys talk about on the pod
or have talked about on the pod which is
you know the power of like crowdsourcing
things like spacex if they want to
develop some new technology they put out
some competition and that tends to
attract more interesting people than you
know if they hire a bunch of recruiters
to go you know find the people in theory
they're looking for
the example the example i think you're
thinking about is they were trying to
figure out some like
were they trying to like decode some
protein or something that helped with
this aids um
medication and they like turned it into
a video game and they'd spent 10 years
trying to solve it and then like a bunch
of video gamers got it done in like
three weeks
yeah
well there's the spacex what's what's
the spacex challenge the one that
everyone knows um is it about x prize
it's just like they're
that's not from space yeah but there's
also yeah that's like a version of that
where they basically just put out the
bounty and then let people let anybody
sort of enter to try to win
okay there's a i feel like there's
another one that spacex does but in any
case like what i'm getting at is
all i mean we work for hubspot there's
all these companies that are trying to
attract like quote unquote top talent
and they're doing it in a way that in
most cases like true top talent like
are you going to want to be like dm'd on
linkedin and go through like a
traditional interview process like
in most cases no and so
my question is why isn't there like a
really
like mischief style recruiting agency
that puts out these challenges that the
smartest people on the internet are like
stoked to solve
just out of the sheer pride
that um they then can funnel potentially
into these companies maybe it's the case
that these people just like would never
want to work for these larger companies
but i just wonder why there isn't a more
creative route i have something
recruiting i have something for you so
this is one of the very first articles
the hustle ever wrote i don't even know
if you can google it anymore it was
literally like we wrote it like two
weeks after starting and it was about my
friend named max and if you uh google uh
ben the hustle google interview or the
hustle secret google interview so my
friend max was teaching himself some i i
gotta remember all the details this was
like six years ago he he was
learning some type of coding some type
of language it was it was like a rare
language and he was typing in all these
things on google like what does blank
mean how do you do blank and after a
while his his chrome browser like went
like looked like the matrix and it said
you look like you might belong to one of
us and and it says we've noticed that
you've been googling a lot about this
type of language and we are hiring for
that would you be interested in applying
here that's amazing and very few people
ever saw this but we wrote an article
about this this article got seen by
millions of people what's it say ben
what was the language
google has a secret interview process
and it landed me a job that's the
headline and and he ended up working
there and it worked it worked
and uh it was wild that's dope and you
know only google can do that because
they own the browser in the search
engine but
uh but what if you were just like what
what if there was just like an app that
just sat on your computer
that basically just tracked everything
you did i know sounds great but like
gave you job opportunities based on what
you do on your computer right like
if it knows that steph is in all these
different like subreddits and it's like
and she's like looking at google trends
and all this stuff
that's like a signal for what type of
person you are like it's actually like a
much higher quality signal in theory
than any job interview you could do
where you're just trying to like present
yourself as a certain way versus like
what you actually do on the internet
right like oh you spend a lot of time in
excel or what you actually do on your
computer it's like you spend a lot of
time in excel you know so
uh we've seen we've seen what your
capabilities are okay if you're doing
macros in excel you could probably
qualify for certain types of jobs and so
i wonder if there's like a thing you
could do like for college students like
hey put this on your computer and like
do you want your first job out of
college like we'll help figure out what
that job should be we'll help get you
like a job opportunity uh just by
putting this like tracker on your
computer
quick interruption do me a favor scroll
down and you're going to see a link to
the hustle so if you want to stay up to
date on the tech and business news you
need to know check out the hustle it's a
daily email i used to help write it i
love it so check it out scroll down
below
sounds very naughty yeah i mean though
yeah i mean i know it's always like a oh
tracking everything on your computer
thing but
the reason i thought of this is because
i watched the q on documentary and in it
they have have you guys heard of like
cicada3301
no no
no it's they covered it in the
documentary but basically it was like
the epitome of these like crazy online
puzzles i think there's been three of
them the first two were solved the third
one still has not been solved and they
are like you know there's there's like a
picture online and there's like a
message and encrypted in that message
there's a bunch of numbers and then you
have to know to like go to another
website and put it in the point is
a lot of people thought that this was
actually a recruitment tool for like
either the nsa or the cia and so i was
like man there should be something maybe
not that crazy but something like that
online for a company did you guys ever
do one of those i did this in college we
found this website
and it was like you know it said some
like vague thing it was like the game
has only begun
but have you realized it like have you
realized that it's begun yet and it's
like you have to like right click view
source and then the source code there's
a url you go to that url and then it
downloads an audio file you listen to
the audio file it sounds like nothing
you listen to it backwards all of a
sudden it gives you coordinates you go
to those coordinates on a map the map
deletion and it was like a 50-part game
like mystery game and me and all my
friends got totally obsessed with this
we spent like hours and hours and now
i don't remember what the name this is
back in college it was like 15 years ago
but like the uh i remember at the end
the the last puzzle
we could never solve and i think the guy
just made an unsolvable puzzle like i
just think there was no solution and his
name was mr wiggles or mr squiggles or
some [__] like that and he um
he had this puzzle that was like the
unsolvable thing at the end but it was
so much fun and actually now that i
think about it that is actually a great
like filter and barometer for who might
be good at certain times of what types
of work like the type of person that
would do that for fun and solve that
problem i would love to hire that person
right because i know
well could you
could you be like uh there's this aw
like if you're that game maker mr
wiggles or whatever like could you like
do that as a service for a variety of
companies uh and like make these games
like hey we're gonna try and find you
but i bet it's like hey i bet we're
gonna do this thing this and this thing
and i bet you we're gonna get you 20 new
applicants every month
yeah these silly games but they're going
to be high high quality
steph what's uh what's newly
so newly have either of you guys heard
no of newly n-u-l-y
i think with this is just a quick one
but basically so it's this company that
is part of the urban outfitters
subsidiary so urban owns urban
outfitters anthropology free people
and newly and newly is a different take
so all those other businesses sell
clothes in a very traditional way what
newly is is a rental business so every
month they send you six items you choose
those six items on your own they send
them to you you get to rent them for a
month and then at the end of the month
you have the option to keep them at
honestly a pretty discounted rate
somewhere between like 15 to sometimes
up to 60 percent and they've a ton of
brands in there including their own
brands and the reason i thought this was
interesting is
you know there's other rental clothing
services out there but this is tacked on
to existing businesses that weren't
renting clothes and it spoke to me
because it was kind of similar to what
amazon's done turning a cost center into
something that maybe in this case isn't
a profit center but is
way more profitable i think than the
traditional clothing business that they
have so if you guys remember i think was
it mark lore or um
one of your guests talked about just how
many returns there are for clothing it's
let me just pull up a stat right here 20
right
yeah exactly and a return
with clothing can cost up to 66
of the the cost of an item so actually a
lot of these closing stores were just
saying like look you can you can just
keep the stuff you don't even have to
send back the item in this case newly
not only
uh it doesn't have to like
send items to people and not have them
returned because it's so expensive i'm
paying newly to rent these clothes so
they're not losing money on the rental
they're now making money on the rental
and they've structured it in a way where
it's actually really compelling and so i
think newly i don't know the exact size
of it now but at least where i live i
run into like at my co-working space all
the girls there
are wearing newly and i just like i
wonder how this can be applied to other
businesses so like what are those cost
centers that could actually be turned
into a profit center sean what's the
return rate on the things that you're
involved in through investments or
whatever this is way lower um
way lower than the 20 so like you know
more like
and i don't know if that's i don't know
if that number is uh like what percent
of your orders get returned or what
percent of your revenue what what what
percent of revenue is the cost of
returns so i'm not sure exactly what
that what that's meant to quote but you
know of course any return is like a
drain on the business and so you you
know any way that you could turn returns
into uh
to either a neutral or profitable thing
would be
would be kind of amazing
what do brands do with returned clothing
or returned items they kind of like so
typically you sort of like there's like
a it's like an er right so the patient
comes in and it's like okay it's it's
it's a lost cause you just gotta dump it
all right right or it's like oh this
could be patched up okay so you just
need to like re-tag it it's in good
condition re-tag it put it back in back
in packaging it's all good to go
sometimes you have to like clean it
steam it whatever like and in fact uh
there's a guy sonny who follows us on
twitter and listens to the pod and he
has this thing called rock returns so i
think he had an e-commerce brand he had
like a suit brand like a nice men's suit
brand
and returns were kind of like killing
him because it's like a very kind of
like heavy thing to ship and it's an
expensive product and um he's like well
what am i supposed to do with this and
his 3pl or like his warehouse was not
like
they weren't willing to um
like reprocess the suit and he couldn't
he couldn't send out a questionable suit
so he had to know that this is like
if it did get if it is going to be set
back out it's in good condition and so
he actually created his own returns
warehouse and he's doing it for himself
and now a bunch of other brands right
same as the aws model so he turned his
cost center into a profit center and i
think this business is better than his
e-commerce business overall and he's
just becoming an expert of like oh yeah
like here's the efficient way to handle
returns and now he's doing it for
himself and a whole bunch of other
e-commerce brands and uh and he's like
nerding out about it hardcore he's like
dude i found this new way of like
steaming the thing that like makes it
you know where we get extra 10 of them
back into circulation because they're
you know they're better now or like we
could turn it around at this cost and
they just charge like a cost per return
processed basically for um
for for the brands
damn that's bad because usually what
makes you good at processing returns is
not the same thing as what gets you good
at like warehouse a general warehouse
with a bunch of pallets and boxes and
shipping orders out it's like takes like
a different skill set in a way
can we talk about uh one other idea yeah
so what you talked about sean reminded
me of so
there's all this real estate and i'm
sure this is like an overdone idea but
there's all this real estate that
people have access to
and not everyone knows what it can be
used for so maybe it could be used for a
fulfillment center maybe your garage
could be rented out and there's a couple
examples that i came upon that i thought
were interesting and i wonder if someone
could aggregate all of these different
ways that real estate or parts of real
estate can be used to gain some income
so let me give you a couple examples a
lot of people have heard of solar panels
so companies will pay you so that you
can install solar panels on your roof
you'll get into a licensing agreement
and they'll make money off of that
that's why they'll often install it for
free
another example is churches so
apparently due to the height of churches
and specifically the steeples on
churches different telecom companies
will pay these churches for access to
their steeple so an example is the
national cathedral in washington is paid
guess how much actually guess how much
they're paid by motorola every single
year
i would have thought like a thousand a
month
so 100 000 a year just for access to
their 234 foot tower
and some churches are even
building steeples they don't even have a
steeple but they're like look i heard
this other church is getting 100k a year
we want that so that's another example
one final example i'll share is surfline
my partner he surfs all the time
he uses these surf cams to check you
know how the waves are every day well
where are these surf cams apparently
they're actually in people's backyards
so if you have a backyard that is in a
strategic area to see the surf
you can either sign up yourself or you
can recommend or refer people to be like
a surf cam house and they'll come
they'll install it and then i believe
you get i'm not actually sure in this
case how much but you get paid a certain
amount to have that surf cam in your
backyard so those are three examples i'm
sure there's many more but i feel like
there should be a site that says like oh
you've got a house in this area you have
a roof that gets this much sunlight or
it's this tall or it's this much square
footage would you go as far as to put
this into cars too one time years ago
shawn and i listened to this pitch of
this guy who created a
you know how cab cabbies have like
advertising on top of their car he was
doing that for uber drivers
and uh i don't actually know i i see him
everywhere but i don't know how the
business what happened with the business
huge valuation so so they definitely got
some traction i think it's like a
multi-hundred million dollar company now
it's called firefly what um wow yeah and
there's another one that has like the
screens have you guys been in ubers
where it's like a screen and it's just
playing ads those ones are i feel like
the execution on that has been terrible
but like that's another example where
it's like oh you actually have valuable
real estate which is the back of this
car seat because you have people i have
an idea for you um
new side project for you it's called the
side hustle generator and we'll put it
on the my first million podcast website
and it's a side hustle generator oh it's
a giant quiz that leads you into a list
of potential side hustles you could be
ethical for so you're like yeah you know
in your thing it's like do you
do you own a church
you know do you do you live by the surf
do you um do you have a car that you
don't use all the time right like
there's all these different
ways because i think you know people um
people don't realize the number of
opportunities that are like literally at
their fingertips it's like do you own a
phone do you know you get paid to test
websites for companies all you have to
do is go to the website and just talk
out loud as you try to use their website
usertesting.com right like
my mom didn't know that and then she
knows that and that like kind of like
changed her life a little bit right she
like all of a sudden had this thing she
could do every day that kept her busy
that made her some money and she enjoyed
it um
then you know airbnb i remember telling
my parents about airbnb it's like
you know took some you know somebody had
to educate them about it but now they
make six figures a year airbnb being
their home and so there's like how many
of these your parents do yeah
where do they go uh they'll just go like
you know to a hotel they'll go to a
vacation they'll just leave the city
they'll come to my house they'll go
anywhere like they don't care because
because they can get like you know 700
800 a night for their home and they'll
go rent a hotel you know
if 40 minutes away or an hour away
they'll go to wine country or whatever
and rent a hotel for 200 and they you
know they pocket the difference
did you guys remember the company about
stuff you do the penny hoarder yeah so
the penny holder started as a blog it
started by this guy named kyle he spoke
at one of our events he's a cool dude
and then his
business partner
is a friend of mine and anyway he
started it in 2012 and he started it
where he would just talk about all the
side hustles he was doing so for example
he would go on taskrabbit and like get
people's groceries and we talk about how
much money he was making he would become
an instacart driver he would talk about
how much money he's making he would do
uber driver and how much money he was
making and he got really good at getting
traffic and eventually he uber goes hey
for every new driver you refer to us
we'll give you two thousand dollars
instacart did the same thing taskrabbit
did the same thing uh you user testing
did the same thing and then like a
person who like you need to answer
surveys and so that's what he did and he
built this business this digital ad
business
um
he when he came to the event he brought
his dog and i was like oh how'd you get
your dog on the plane he goes oh i fly
private and i was like what are you
crushing it that hard he goes yeah we
bootstrapped it and we'll do about 70
million in revenue this year and he
owned 100 of the company and he recently
sold it for i forget the exact number
but it was in the hundreds of millions
of dollars and the whole premise was
just on like talking about ways that you
can make it was mostly lower income
people like people like like maybe a mom
who's just trying to like make ends meet
with just like 10 hours that she has
available instead of taking care of kids
and um
he killed it this business crushed it
you've never heard of the penny holder
sean i heard i've heard it from you but
i never went to it so i never like used
it it's just a wordpress blog that's all
it is
uh sorry i was looking forward to stuff
stock and realizing how many interesting
ideas there are in here steph we have to
do a two-parter so uh
so yeah let's
let her bang out a couple more let's
give us one more i'll come back any time
i mean that was the worst ideas in the
middle of the list was the best idea so
that's my feedback to you well why don't
you tell me what's an interesting one
that you you have you're right i'm
looking at some of these like trend
success stories i think those are pretty
interesting um
that's one i was kind of looking at just
at the moment which one of those is your
favorite
hmm well i feel like okay so let's call
out a couple of them real quick so last
time i was on i talked about like this
idea of like your listicle is my
opportunity a couple people have
actually taken action on that they've
created these sites that identify the
healthiest versions of not very healthy
things so one guy started a tick-tock it
got hundreds of thousands of views in
the first few days
and then someone else tweeted about this
actually this just last night
let me see what they did they're called
fast food cravings where basically the
headline says eat what you want not what
you can and it lets you like put in a
specific restaurant and find the
healthiest version of the food at that
restaurant we talked about insider
trading at on one of the very first
episodes i was on and this guy after
that episode i think this actually
existed before the episode but
connor dm'd me and he was like
so there are these sites that track
insider trades but there are specific
types of insider trades that are more
interesting than others and specifically
it's stock grants to executives it's not
obviously a sure thing but he said he
was like
typically what that signals is
the company trying to you know invest in
a particular thing if the executives hit
certain targets it's generally a good
sign obviously not investment advice but
he created this community called spring
loading
and what he does is he started a scraper
that looks for
all the insider trades but then
specifically vets them for this
particular aspect like is the company
granting a buttload of stock to a group
of executives
and he just he's he basically shares
these and then he i
shared an example in the chat but he
basically he sends the
uh financial report he sends the grant
details then he summarizes it he says
look these people are getting this grant
this is what i have you know what
additional information i have and then
he gives a conviction rating so some of
his conviction ratings are like one like
guys this is probably nothing maybe
something if you want to take a bet go
for it some of them he's like this is a
five so i shared one again not
investment advice but he shared one for
example for cloudflare a little bit ago
obviously cloudflare with all the other
tech companies is tanked recently but
he was like this is one of the biggest
performance grants i've ever seen
with pretty massive price targets i
don't think there's any news in the near
future but i do believe that cloudflare
has massive potential and the stock is
down 35 over the last month and then he
shares again the exact grant values what
targets they need to hit so for example
these execs have different price targets
similar to
you know you guys discuss like elon
musk's like crazy price targets if they
hit i think um cloudflare today is at 95
or something like that their first price
target is 156 dollars and it goes all
the way up to
979 dollars so this is what these execs
internally are tracking towards so i
don't know i thought that was like
another interesting example i think he's
i think this community is pretty
successful he's charging people monthly
fees by this idea did you bet on this
i haven't uh cal
my partner he's been in the community he
did actually i mean again not financial
advice but he bet on one and i can't
remember what company it was but it did
one one day like go up
but this was obviously also in the uh
don't even tell me more actually just
leave it there and i'm convinced don't
even i don't i don't need anything else
well i was gonna say i definitely like
don't want people to be go going and
gambling their money on on that one
anecdote but it is interesting to even
just like be in there and and what i've
found because i'll just like dabble in
the community i haven't placed any bets
but to see
um what like i'm learning about a bunch
of different companies that i've never
heard of i'm seeing like how these
different companies are structuring
stock grants and like why and someone
commenting on it and then of course
there's just like a bunch of um
a bunch of people commenting like are
you betting like oh [__] like i'm 50
down like how are you doing and it's so
it's kind of like a fun community as
well you guys have this is awesome you
guys have a uh like a
like a degenerate
budget or like a learner budget where
it's like okay
this is my [__] around with money that i
can i can try different things or do you
guys not do that same you're shaking
your head no i don't but
but do you it sounds like you do i do
yeah
how much
uh well let's talk about like in
percentage terms so it's like you know
what would that be it's like
don't do percentage terms like literally
how much like like 50 50 000 no more
than that uh
wow yeah for sure and so what will you
do with that what's an example of your
of a dumb of a risky thing that you've
done uh like
i think i've told this story before but
i remember watching uh so the idea with
these is um
i'll just tell the story first i watched
a youtube video of this guy no idea who
this guy is uh some wall street some
some hedge fund guy and basically he's a
prolific short trader this is kind of
like the vibe i got from this video
couldn't tell you how to tell you his
name couldn't tell you what his track
record was
uh white guy looked reasonable enough
and uh he basically was like he's like
yeah i'm uh he's like my short pick of
the year is tootsie roll
and uh and all these i was like well i
was listening i was a white white
tootsie roll i didn't realize it's a
public stock he's like tootsie roll he's
like first of all who the hell eats
tootsie roll he's like do you think
tootsie roll is growing he's like no the
people eat tootsie rolls are like you
know 50 and up
their dying market kids don't want
tootsie roll nowadays they want like all
these other candies he's like tootsie
roll has zero innovation they refuse to
change their product and um they don't
come out with anything new he's like and
then it's also
poorly run and not gonna be so it was
like owned by some woman who was like
i think it's owned by like a 92 year old
lady she passed away now but at the time
this was like five years ago or
something like that like that that this
happened i don't know where this was it
was a while back and um i remember
watching that video and i was like oh
this guy's totally right titsurl is
[__] dead i went that day and i
better get stitcher roll i made a bunch
of money just on this like zero thought
process zero diligence
like just like take it take a punt and
uh you know do something on a whim
and so that was the first time i
realized like
actually i want a designated budget and
with crypto this has become like you
know kind of a necessity with crypto you
basically have like
you have so many new things that are all
interesting and you can't get to high
conviction because they're new it's
rapidly evolving like the opportunities
in front of you today and so you don't
have time to diligence all these you
don't have time to get to high
conviction but you do know like
where
you know you can sort of sense certain
signals like if a bunch of smart people
are looking at it um if you see you know
developer activity in that space if the
premise is like
you know interesting it might hit might
not hit whatever you can basically take
punts on things in crypto and you get
paid off
unlike the stock market right i think on
the tootsie roll thing i made like i
don't know 20 35 something like that
in crypto you can make like 20 x when
you're right on these things and so
with krypto the odds just shift in your
favor where yeah it's super fast moving
and things can go to zero but the
the upside when you hit is so high it
pays for all of your other bad bets and
so i basically created a budget because
i was like i can't um
i can't overthink this i need to i need
to intentionally underthink this so what
does that mean it's like there's been
in the last five years there's been so
many examples of things that i've come
across my radar in crypto
that i don't take action on because i
feel like i don't have enough
information to make an educated decision
and actually if i had just made
uneducated decisions i would have done
far better than my like educated
decisions turned out to be because
the space is just um
where there's a lot of progress being
made and you can't keep up with all the
different projects all different tokens
so i basically set out a budget where i
said if somebody tells me something
that's interesting
i have money that i could just like dump
into that it's a small amount of money i
don't care if that money that money goes
to zero and i'm not putting it all into
one so i'm taking like a portfolio of
these and let's just see what happens
and in doing so i get to actually learn
how these things work um
and so you know like i did one the other
day and i put it in the milk road
explaining literally step by step
what this what this project was and why
i'm why i'm going into it and how i have
no idea if this is like a great idea a
bad idea i didn't audit the security of
the project like i don't have time for
all that i'm just like
trying to learn how these things work
and i'm putting small bets in a bunch of
different areas with money that i can
afford to lose do you do that stuff so i
don't cal does uh i think it's smart
though because like sean saying
these are the type of investments where
like if you don't have money sequestered
for this it's gonna
it's gonna capture your psychology
that's actually why i don't dabble in
these things but uh he's done that a lot
for nfts right so at first he was like
steph i'm just gonna buy one obviously
he's bought bought more since then but
he
he has a certain amount and like that's
all he's willing to invest if it goes to
zero he's happy with it um but he's also
probably sold a lot too early because he
has a concentrated amount so he's like
oh i gotta sell this to buy another
thing uh sean did you get into proof i
feel like that was a big no i didn't i
didn't do proof
that's that's a great example of one
where i'm like oh interesting kevin rose
is doing this nft thing
i should uh
i should you know i should take a punt
right like it's i'm seeing this before
most people
um i should go in and like again like
with these things it's not gonna it's
not like gonna go to zero quote unquote
it's like you know so i can trade out of
the thing if i want to and you know
three months from now but like
to weigh each to i don't want every
decision to be heavy and um
and i you have you guys seen this meme
that's like the
it's like the curve i think it's called
like the midwit meme it's basically like
there's an idiot on one side there's a
genius like i said on one side is the
idiot he looks like a troll it looks
like you know it's like whatever shrek
and on the other side there's like a
jedi master
and then the middle which is like the
top of the curve is like the average
person and it's like uh you know like
for example like oh like the idiot would
be like oh that monkey looks like that's
a cool looking monkey i'll buy all right
the genius is like oh this you know this
has a chance to be an iconic you know
like like whatever iconic nft bi i
didn't think about it more than that and
then the like middle guy is like you
know but why would anybody buy this
picture of a monkey and like how do the
tokenomics work and they try to like
analyze the whole [__] thing and
they're hey they're just paralyzed
that's some sort of analysis paralysis
where they don't they don't take action
on anything and they overthink things so
they miss the like the big simple
opportunities that are in front of them
a lot of times and um i heard the guy
from yc
who michael seibel talking about this he
goes he goes this is often the case with
startup ideas he goes
a beginner like you know you out of
college when you don't know anything
about anything you just think it's all
like
you don't you don't know how hard it's
going to be
you don't know what a good you don't
know how to vet opportunities you just
be like oh that sounds cool like let me
try that
and then same thing with the jedi master
the jedi master's like oh like you know
would it be cool if you could take a
rocket to mars let's try that you know
like
that's also the like you don't need to
analyze it beyond that at the beginning
it's like this fundamental decision is
pretty it's very simple and then like
the person he's like the person i hate
talk to talking to is like the second
time founder who's trying to like over
optimize their cap table and like try to
get like really complicated about the
like the valuation and this and then
that and then they're trying to do like
this lean validation about every single
thing
and it's like that's the hardest person
to deal with because they're
they know too much but not enough to
know how to keep it simple and uh he's
talking about like the best ideas the
best startup ideas
they go to like that that idiot genius
category where it's like
you know like you should make cars that
are electric you know like we should
we should sell books online yeah it's
like yeah what if we could buy a book
online
and it's like
that's it right you don't need to go too
much further than that what's uh what's
that video called uh it's a it's one of
the y combinator it's it's michael cyble
and this guy dalton caldwell they do
like a split screen side by side and
they just talk about something for 30
minutes and this is one of them uh i
don't remember the name of the video do
you know the name of the title
i can find it uh real quick while you
guys talking but i don't know by the way
believe in that like this idea of the
sort of like idiot genius like don't
overthink it thing
well i just did the idea i just did the
idea well go ahead step i'll let you go
first well i was just gonna say quickly
like
yes i believe in it and yes i think it
applies to like different things so i
would say i'm the like would you call it
like mid-twit or something uh somewhere
in the middle for like midwit in in
finance that's why i don't dabble
because i'm like i over analyze things i
hear one piece of news i'm out kind of
kind of deal but um i think it applies
to like with startups i think i'm
maybe not that with other things i
certainly am like just just terrible and
so i think it i think our friendship
applies a great example of this right
like he saw nfts and was like oh that
looks cool like i'm gonna buy one i'm
gonna make one uh what should i make it
of i don't know like this i don't know
this diagram i already have
like you know it's like the simplest
[__] and the guys did millions of
dollars this year
how much how much do you think he's made
off those how much do you think he's
made on is he do you think he's like
wildly wealthy from those uh i don't
know you know he he's done well for sure
i think you know he he bought apes he
bought he bought a punk i think he's
bought some of the like the projects
that went up from like for sure you know
and plural like you said like apes not
not like one ap he's bought multiple of
all i think those were like priced at
like you know i thought whatever like a
thousand dollars like you know 18 months
ago
and now each one is worth like you know
250 500 000 so i don't know if he held i
don't know what it was but even just the
the stuff he made right like i know a
lot of people are like oh web3 the
metaverse i need to create an empty
project he needs to have this and that
and utility blah blah
he's like
hey i minted a picture of like a you
know a thing that says not like not like
right click save as you know it's kind
of like just making fun of the space
sold it for like fifty thousand dollars
right like did that in an afternoon
and uh that's like the mid you know
instead of being the midwit over
analyzer logical
you know processor of all things you
know he went to the kind of the genius
zone and uh just took a punt and it
because he's in the genius zone it's not
heavy it doesn't take a lot of time or
energy or money to like try it and so
i i specifically carved out a portion of
my investing budget to say look this is
my my gamble like you know i'll get rid
of my gambling energy i'll learn by
doing this because i'll do things that i
wouldn't otherwise do
and i'll have skin in the game so i'll
actually pay attention to it um and like
who knows you know maybe i'll maybe i'll
have some have some hits out of this
and i bet i honestly think that that
part of my portfolio is gonna do better
than the the well thought through
quote-unquote part of my portfolio by
the way sam i think you do this really
well when people like i've seen people
come to you and they're like sam i'm
thinking of like
starting this business and like i want
to cover this topic and i want to blog
and all this stuff and you're like all
right like what's your first step or
like you you'll be like
just right or something like that which
just like simplifies to the like idiot
jedi like just do the thing not like
over analyzing the like 50 startup
articles when sam says dying dog he just
needed
he goes randy jackson on him
well i get i just get frustrated i think
because i think that like i think that
it's good so if like building a business
is step 0 to 10 and 10 is like you're
this billionaire or like your vision has
been achieved you know you you you own
all this property whatever it is it's
good to have number ten and then
a lot of people are like all right
that's step number ten and then like
steps three four five six seven eight
nine i gotta figure those out in my mind
i'm like no but the only thing that's
important is ten and one and one after
you get done with one you'll figure out
number two just but until you get to
number two don't even think about
worrying about number three it's not
important dude i have the same exact
thing i i call it a b z
literally like word for word your thing
and i i went on jax to jack's community
he asked me to give a talk into his like
uh visualize value community and i this
was the one thing i told him i go
you you have you're at a that's where
you are
z is the vision it's the dream it's good
to have that it's good to know what that
is right that's like the north star and
like without that you know you don't
really have the motivation i don't
really understand like what the hell
you're trying to do
but where everyone gets paralyzed is
they think they need to know a step b c
d e f g h i j and it's like and then
they get paralyzed or they start
thinking about step d when they haven't
even done
you know a to b yet and so i go a b z
it's all you ever need it's like where
you are you got to know that accurately
the next thing you need to do you need
to know that and then you need to know
the end vision and everything else is
irrelevant like just do that and so you
just literally said the same thing with
your own like with numbers basically
instead that's awesome great
great minds think alike i mean that's
exactly how i feel because i every time
i've ever had any bit of success or even
when i've like done something and it
didn't work out i just think that like
if you just start and you're gonna see
so many things that you didn't even
expect or realize were an opportunity
and or that weren't an opportunity
you're like oh i thought this it's
actually way different but that's cool
or that's not cool we gotta quit uh you
know what i mean and uh you just that's
why you just have to do something um i
have this and i get really frustrated
with inaction i've been saying this
lately uh i love thin books and quick
silence
and so what does that mean like
i love a thing did you make that up yeah
i love a thin book because a thin book
is like a simple idea
presented without the fluff and that's
it that's the value you know don't try
to you don't need a thick book uh for
everything so i'm a big fan of thin
books now and the other one is a quick
silence which is i call my buddy sue leo
about every business question i have
basically it's like oh we're starting
the milk road hey what do you think
about this and then
there's a quick silence like he says his
thing
it's obvious that's the answer and i was
like building up in my head i need to
like oh man i really want to sit down
with him and talk it's like within three
minutes
we've reached a good pause where it's
like well i guess nothing else really
matters till we go do that right yep
all right well
i guess i'll just do that obviously yeah
check you later
like and so that quick silence to me is
like now what i want was i used to want
to fill that silence with
more detail more analysis more planning
more
uh nuance more like if then statements
and like
you don't really need any of that like
we talk by the end of my sentence he
says his sentence
uh sorry for i guess i didn't really
need a call i guess i could have just
done a text and you know like i guess i
kind of knew this to begin with like
maybe i didn't need to call you right
but that quick silence is really
showing me like
that's when i'm on the right track is
when i get either a thin book or a quick
silence is like when i'm on the right
track and when i need more answers uh
typically i'm just i'm actually going in
the wrong direction altogether dude yeah
that reminds me uh from coding if you uh
if you run into an error and you're on
like stack overflow or something and
you're just like you're you can't find
your answer it's probably because you're
googling the wrong thing like you've
completely messed it up you're in the
complete wrong direction um and i feel
like that applies in in most cases if
you find yourself asking like 10
questions it's like hold up like you are
you're just like going in the complete
opposite direction that you should be
like pull back and revisit
how many people reach out to you after
each one of these episodes goes live
stuff and said that they like want to
pitch you on something or they want to
recruit you to come join something
well it grows and some of your buddies
reach out which is always fun but i feel
like um we're talking about what
we're talking about i don't want to drop
anything
dummy that sounds like a story what's
behind that
no no i just mean like it's cool because
well also i should say like some people
that i've really looked up to i don't
want to call out their names because i
don't obviously these are like private
messages but people that i've looked up
to that i was like oh i used to read
your stuff or like i've literally read
your book or like
we're from the same country
i'm not naming eddie james but uh it's
been cool and it's grown obviously
because you guys have grown the pod a
lot um so yeah
that's amazing well there's few people
i'll get a fistfight over you are one of
them steph so let me know who uh
you haven't broken your contract sam so
you're good
uh well good i'm happy you came you have
so much more to cover i think we should
wrap up here though yeah sorry i
actually apologize i ever do listen to
this because
steph had a bunch of gold and i feel
like i took it in these really random
directions so to make up for it we're
going to do a second part of staff if
you'll come back and we'll do more of
these ideas rapid fire and i'll shut up
yeah i'm down let's do it
[Music]